the United States came to the U.N
security Council to make a point we're
going to condemn those sham elections in
here this morning and we will never
recognize any of these elections on
Ukrainian occupied territory the U.S
along with Albania called the meeting to
discredit elections currently underway
and four russian-controlled regions in
Ukraine the Voting is to select local
candidates to the Russian installed
legislatures and coincides with
elections currently happening in Russia
Russia's Ambassador insisted ukrainians
were exercising their right to
self-determination
it is the inhumane Crimes of the Kiev
regime and its maniacal hopeless desire
to deprive the Russian people of their
Russian identity that became the main
reason due to which the residents of
Donetsk luhansk and zaparesia are
actively and consciously voting for
their future together with Russia
saying that Russia's annexation of
Ukrainian territory is illegal and that
the elections have no validity under
international law and the majority of
U.N member States agree
back in 2022 143 countries in the
general assembly condemned Russia for a
similar round of illegal referendums as
Ukraine's Ambassador reminded the
Gathering Friday in the security Council
we call on the International Community
to condemn the use of the Russian
election system on the territory of
another state but this year the council
took no action
so was vetoed by Russia Kristen salumi
Al Jazeera the United Nations
Colombia and Mexico are co-host
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera